so um the ring okay um when you look at
it right or even at the bus okay it's
awfully democratic very egalitarian as
if you know all of these computers are
all created equal and we you know are
recognized they all have their rights to
cuss you life and happiness or something
anyway
in real life nodes are almost never
created equal
always never okay because some are more
important than others and some are less
important than others right so that gave
birth to a kind of topology called the
star the staff
what's a star look like well you'll have
what node in the middle okay which has
illusions of grandeur and says look I'm
the most important guy here all the rest
of you guys you connect to me okay now
what that guy in the middle is it can
they can change depending on DeMaio what
kind of network this is right but how
does it work if Yui wants to communicate
with another they must go through this
Center thing
okay and the center thing could be a
variety things it could be another
computer just a regular order it could
be a kind of server like a proxy server
or a web server or a file server
it could be just like a modem or a hub
or a switch or a router and we're going
to talk about all the differences
between those the key is there's one
thing that everyone else was connected
to okay if a message was the pass from
here to here you've got to go through
that central node okay now just quick
advantages okay can you see this
overcomes that last weakness for the
talking about right which is that if one
of these nodes is busted okay so long as
it's not the one that you're
communicating with no problems okay
this guy gets busted it breaks down the
whole ring okay and there's a traffic
jam but here if you want to communicate
with this one and this one gets busted
no problems okay just keep on going
but by the same token token sorry I
don't mean to say that um by the same
concept principle if this guy in the
middle the central node is busted on
everything is catastrophic oh okay and
in fact that can mean more than what you
got up here right in a ring network if
one is busted right that means you can't
communicate with the rest of the people
in the network but you might be
inconvenient to you but at least you can
keep on working away okay but often what
you have here in a star network members
telling you before about file service
which is like a glorified high drive so
you often get this kind of arrangement
when your computer's here on the edges
right which we often call clients these
clients they don't have any hard drive
storage space of their own right and so
all of this stuff their files their
programs are stored here when this guy
goes down these guys don't like ah it's
a bit inconvenient but we'll just keep
on marching on these guys ceased to
function okay they lose basic abilities
okay so it really depends on what this
central guy is okay so it can go both
ways it can be less redundant or it
could be more okay that's the starter
work I already talked through some of
these let's get going
um this standard work it works when
there's one kind of node which is more
important than others okay but sometimes
you don't just have one that is more
important than all the rest right you've
got a whole hierarchy of ones that are
more important than others okay so
sometimes you get diagnosed something
like this the topology it looks like
this
what's this um now if you look at it
kind of upside down kinda looks like a
free right I suppose you could actually
say it looks like a tree's roots
I guess I'm drawing it upside down
because this tends to mean like I said
hierarchy before right so this is a
hierarchical sort of design and the more
important nodes are closer to the top
this is actually often called a
hierarchy okay so you often will get
this in an organization or a company
okay you're like if you might be a pleb
down here and you only need to know or
be connected to your managers computer
and these guys only need to be connected
to you know the VP of their section or
whatever it is okay now run out of time
so I'll quickly just tell you what the
last one is and draw it and I'll leave
the advantages/disadvantages to you the
last one is where you've got a set of
computers right but it just won't do in
terms of security or in terms of speed
to be able to connect to just the next
guy and the next guy and the next guy
and the next guy you need some more
direct connections so what we do is you
draw more I think I'm done actually let
me sat in one more there we go okay so
what's this what's it look like well
physically the closest [ __ ] they call
this to use a mesh right so there are
two kinds of mesh there's a full mesh
like this one where everything is
connected to everything else okay and
there's what we call a partial mesh
which is um you're connected to multiple
ones but not necessarily every single
okay so